do they do they watch everything you do
they do they're really supportive yeah I
used when I was on girls I got this
question a lot and it like made people
feel extremely weird because that show
was
um
I'm glad you have to bring them back for
this that show was um
you're scary as hell yeah it was scary
like luckily they understand me but you
know girls was like but yes they're very
supportive they watch everything I do we
have it down to kind of a science on
girls by the time we finished I'd be
like okay I got the um episodes for the
season there will be six sex scenes
they're gonna be in these episodes
exactly just to be like here's how you
need to dose out your adrenaline for the
whole here's when you fast forward
exactly exactly yeah so I love the
support though too oh I feel so lucky
and those are grown adults that can
handle that too that's nice that's a
healthy family nice because we all I
mean like the whole bunch our whole
family we all went to the Megan premiere
for example a couple weeks ago and all
six of us are kind of in various
versions of this business from one angle
or another it's a joke in our house is
like if you need a makeup wipe all of us
have a solution every one of us my
brother's on TV my dad's on TV my mom is
a producer my um my sister-in-law is
also like in the business and my partner
is an actor so if you need to remove
makeup if you need a makeup suggestion
there are five other people in our house
yeah you are covered that's kind of cool
that you're all in the business in some
form yeah that's kind of nice because
you understand yeah yeah you understand
the demand and then we support system is
awesome yeah
[Music]
all right
[Applause]
[Music]